bienvenue dans génération europe nous
sommes ici à la cité internationale
universitaire de paris au collège franco
britannique pour notre deuxième émission
de génération europe
notre thème aujourd'hui le citoyen
européen
existe-t-il vraiment nous en parlerons
avec nos étudiants européens qui sont là
mais aussi avec notre invité rama yade
bienvenue à vous tous à leur d'emblée
j'ai envie de vous poser cette question
est ce que vous vous sentez sur tout
citoyen européen ou plutôt nationale
lisa je me sens allemande mais je me
sens aussi européenne donc par exemple
quand comme j'ai dit ici en france quand
je parle avec tes français et je suis la
seule au monde
je me sens quand même assez un monde et
je vois les différences un peu entre moi
et les français ou ceux des autres
nations mais quand je parle avec les
gens qui ne viennent pas de l'europe ou
aussi quand je suis avec un groupe du
rhdp 1 surtout quand je suis avec un
groupe de jeunes de mon âge par exemple
comme ici par exemple à la décision
européenne de rehab c'est de travailler
ce qu'ils sont plutôt national européen
chloé alors je me sens justement plus
européenne parce que mon père y ma mère
et chypriotes et je suis né à paris donc
serait que je pour moi c'est plus facile
de dire europe
j'ai trois métiers un passeport qui est
doux de la république de chypre en fait
et dessus alors est ce que ces écritures
et donc non à l'europe n'est pas
mentionné
comme depuis quand en 2006 c'était deux
ans après que chypre adhérer à l'union
européenne est normalement est-ce que ça
apparaît surtout les passeports par
exemple johan toi tu es génial je ne me
semble plus européen que d'espagnols qui
te sens plus européen que tania espagne
c'est une étape plurinational ma nation
c'est le catalan alors nous sommes nous
font partie d'une union et celle
européenne alors je me réveille pas avec
tous les jours avec l'âge je suis
européen mais constituent mes demandes
je suis
oui je les ai la motivation c'est je
suis une citoyens européens et les
français sentent français où sont
européens je pense que c'est vraiment
quand on quand on quitte le continent
enfin notamment je passe les pinces ici
quelques un voyage un peu au canada ou
aux états unis
là on se rend compte vraiment que ya une
culture européenne et que on est vu par
les autres comme le vieux continent
comme et plus même que j'ai en étant
juste français ou du parisien où tout
ses intérêts européens dans le regard
des autres mais pas dans ton coeur à toi
quoi moi je suis français mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais me sentir plus
européen mai sur le passeport qu'est-ce
qui a écrit l'union européenne
république française et si tu compares
par rapport à l'espagne d'aller voir la
différence c'est qu'il n'ya pas
république espagnole
ouais ça c'est de la prime est différent
un bonheur espagnol s'est créé un énorme
une analyse psychologique des états les
états ça veut dire que la france est
mieux dans sa peau se sont dits plus
européenne que les espagnols
effectivement oui et puis surtout fait
que enfin l'union européenne apparaît
avant la république française ce à ses
fins symboliquement je veux dire ça a
quelque chose d'important que les deux
semaines sur le se mettre sur le même
plan et antonello alors toi tu embrasses
port il a heureusement j'avais pas de
passeport
il faut en italie marco parce que j'ai
jamais voyagé hors de l'europe et donc
j'ai jamais eu besoin d'un passeport et
peut-être maintenant que tout le monde 2
sort son passeport je me rends compte
que ça pourrait être une expression de
ce que l'europe a baptisé six mois comme
italien avec ma carte d'identité
italienne qu'en plus elle est bleue à la
trace de tous les autres et italiens qui
est marrant parce que je viens d'une
région autonome qui est la vallée
d'aoste
tout en haut rhin près du mont blanc où
il ya le jambon d'aoste n'a rien à voir
pour les français de la recherche de
gens vont pas chez toi exactement le
genre on danse
les français donc c'est tout à fait une
région autonome et bilingues dont ça
fait rire parce que seulement quatre
identités il est écrit républicain
italien la république italienne en
français
et du coup j'ai jamais eu besoin de
faire un passeport pour voyager en
europe
ça peut être c'est symptômes du travail
que l'europe a fait allez je vous
propose de revenir tout de suite aux
fondamentaux sur le sujet on va parler
de qu'est ce qui définit le citoyen
européen je vous propose tout de suite
le reportage de thierry scharff mise en
image par hugo nicolas c'est l'essentiel
il faut bien le reconnaître la
construction de l'europe s'est jusqu'ici
surtout préoccupés d'économies ceci
étant dit depuis le traité de maastricht
de 1992 le citoyen européen est entrée
de plein droit dans les textes
communautaires et citoyens de l'union
toute personne ayant la nationalité d'un
état membre la citoyenneté européenne
s'ajoute donc à la citoyenneté nationale
d'ailleurs la définition juridique du
citoyen européen n'existe nulle part
elle résulte d'une somme de textes issus
de divers traités et d'arrêt de la cour
de justice européenne de tout ça ressort
tout de même quatre endroits spécifiques
du citoyen européen premièrement la
libre
circulation au sein de l'europe réservez
au départ aux seuls travailleurs le
droit de séjour c'est aujourd'hui
élargie à tous au moins de façon
théorique car dans les faits tous les
citoyens européens ne jouissent pas de
la même souplesse partout en europe
deuxième droits du citoyen européen le
droit de vote et d'éligibilité aux
élections municipales et européennes
mais pas question de devenir maire ou
adjoint non mais troisième droits du
citoyen européen
la protection diplomatique et consulaire
une façon de mettre à égalité tous les
européens à l'extérieur de l'europe
enfin quatrième droits du citoyen
européen le droit de pétition devant le
parlement européen et de recours au
médiateur européen un million de
citoyens issus de plusieurs pays peuvent
inviter la commission à soumettre une
proposition d'actes juridiques à l'union
sur un sujet particulier un droit tout
nouveau mis en place en avril dernier la
citoyenneté européenne
un chantier à ben ami la citoyenneté
européenne un chantier vient de dire
thierry charles
qu'est ce que tu en penses gel c'est un
chantier actuellement je pense que l'une
identité ça se crée aussi parce qu'on a
les mêmes droits on a les mêmes
conditions de vie les mêmes conditions
de travail et c'est vraiment pas le cas
actuellement d'un pays à l'autre les
conditions de vie peuvent changer
les salaires varient énormément et donc
du coup je pense que l'identité
s'inscrire entre par sa part des progrès
sociaux est ce pas le cas actuellement
lorraine moi je me sens très européenne
aussi parce que je suis né aux pays bas
le parti faire mes études en angleterre
et je pense que quand on est européen on
a toutes ces possibilités qui s'ouvrent
et que dans certaines régions du monde
enfin c'est pas forcément possible et je
pense que le chantier européen et enfin
personnellement quasiment terminé on va
continuer à parler de la citoyenneté
européenne est ce que ce sens citoyen
européen ou pas est ce qu'on l'a et
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on l'ait je vous
propose qu'on accueille tout de suite
notre invité aujourd'hui qui rama yade
ça a un sens pour vous d'être citoyen
européen
je le suis sur le papier je me suis
quand je suis hors des frontières
européennes
mais c'est pour moi c'est encore en
chantier en construction vous avez
proposé d'être députée européenne ya
cinq ans l'europe vous rattrape
maintenant est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la façon de se sentir
européen a changé sur les cinq dernières
années
chantier il se fait une semaine je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux
je pense qu'on peut faire mieux parce
que depuis en cinq ans bon il ya le
traité de lisbonne qui entrait en
vigueur mais ça s'est passé dans les
circonstances quand même assez difficile
puisque les boîtes nationaux n'étaient
pas forcément favorable quand il ya eu
vote
et quand ya pas eu vote c'est à dire
qu'on est passé par le parlement là les
contestations de des europhobes et des
eurosceptiques ont été quand même forte
sur le thème parce qu'on a rejeté le
traité de 2005 vous passez par la
fenêtre via le traité de lisbonne
donc il ya quand même encore un travail
de pédagogie à faire d'information je
sais pas s'il est tout le monde le sait
mais 2013 c'est l'année du citoyen
européen
voilà une girl fallu qu'il se passe des
choses que le citoyen européen s'élève
pour son attendus début 2014 maintenant
pour l'écouter peut-être qu'il vaut mais
mais en tout cas pour l'union européenne
c'est l'année du sein européens savent
appliquer quoi bas
on sait pas justement parce que rien ne
s'est vu peut-être que je suis en fait
mais rien de ses vues et c'est ça le
problème c'est pas tant est-ce que
citoyen européen existe que comment on
le fait vivre comment on le met en avant
comment il existe dans l'espace
politique économique sociale culturelle
donc c'est ça peut être super peut-être
sur laquelle il faut travailler moi je
serais pour qui m c'est pas moi 1 tv5
wifi européen pour qu'on ait les infos
qu'ils viennent d'abord de l'europe
euronews mais vous voyez il faut vous
mettre plus en avant ça et puis il faut
aller dans le canal je suis pas combien
loin derrière physique sénat pour avoir
lieu et puis les élections européennes
par exemple ses cales puissant 19 mai on
devrait voter le même jour peut-être
pour donner un sentiment d'appartenir
voilà à une même naissante il va aussi
autre chose c'est-à-dire que est-ce que
vous commenciez à l'évoquer sur comment
s'est construit un petit peu le citoyen
au t1 mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas tout
simplement juste défini par rapport au
droit et à la loi oui c'est bien une
sorte de manque de visibilité là dessus
et les institutions européennes
justement sont quand même assez mauvaise
là dessus pour expliquer ce qui se passe
est clair en fait tout simplement
mais c'est vrai que enfin une
citoyenneté c'est pas que des droits
ceux ci une culture c'est un sentiment
d'appartenir à une communauté
puisqu'on parle de nationalité
européenne et si on allait un petit peu
plus loin écoutez ce que vous propose
tout de suite notre partenaire de
technikart
olivier magny je crois que ce qui est
clair pour beaucoup de gens c'est que
l'identité européenne c'est d'abord des
valeurs communes la liberté la libre
circulation des personnes et puis la
démocratie un jour nous aurons peut-être
un passeport européen nous tous une
identité juridique européenne
mais à quoi ça nous servirait vraiment
d'avoir une identité européenne
à une époque où on voit qu'on
s'intéresse de plus en plus en même
temps au local au terroir bref à ce
qu'il fait qu'on est une petite partie
de l'europe et pas un vaste ensemble ils
parlent d'une identité européenne et
savoir ce que ça veut dire dans un monde
qui devient de plus en plus locales etc
mais ce mouvement là il se fait quand
même à côté d'un autre mouvement qui est
assez important qui s'appelle la
mondialisation et
c'est là dessus que l'identité
européenne elle est vraiment importante
on a hissé à l'extérieur de l'europe
c'est pour exister dans une
mondialisation qui devient de plus en
plus compliqués à assumer pour une
france qui reste compétitive mais qui a
quelques problèmes vis-à-vis de la chine
et les puissances émergentes et l'union
européenne
c'est quand même le premier marché
mondial 500 millions d'habitants de
consommateurs aussi et si on veut
exister à mon avis dans cette course là
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut ils ont ça
protège en effet face à la globalisation
et la mondialisation il n'empêche que
face au régionalisme on le voit bien
avec notre catalan enfin bien avec notre
val d'aoste y un bal d'automne
valdôtains je ne le dit pas assez
souvent il de rien est ce que c'est pas
aussi l'europe c'est pas aussi la
solution face à la nation à laquelle
peut-être vous ne croyez pas tant que ça
l'italie tu y crois je crois plus à
l'europe
évidemment parce que quand même l'état
nation italien des issues historique n'a
jamais existé par contre je me perçois
valdes autant je suis contente de mon
autonomie de ma région
et pourtant j'ai plus pour moi c'est
plus simple de ne concevoir européenne
oui que italien c'est le même que moi je
me sente catalan après si tu veux faire
leur niche une échelle je suis catalan
je suis le barcelonais jeu catalan je
suis européen qu'elle johan tué
barcelonais il n'y a pas ni j'ai
confiance plus avec le avec l'europe
occupée avec l'espagne
cette élection parce que le régionalisme
n'est pas forcément une
un débat contre l'européanisme exact
c'est complémentaire
c'est même une complicité exact en ce
sens où tous les mouvements régionaux
ont pu se protéger grâce à l'europe et
donc les régionalistes comme les
européens s'entendent sur le dos des
nations figé mais moi par exemple moi je
monsieur je me sens français dans le
sens où parce que je sais que tous les
français ont les mêmes droits je reviens
un peu sur cette histoire de droits
sociaux mais ça me semble important
quand même le jour où tout ça ce sera
peut-être harmoniser vers le haut
peut-être qu'il y aura une identité
européenne
et la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que là on est rassemblée ici on
est tous à peu près étudiants il ya des
gens qui peuvent venir en erasmus et
tout mais c'est pas la majorité des gens
et c'est pas la majorité des jeunes
notamment pour les races russe parce que
qu'on soit français espagnol et tout
pour partir en erasmus il ya des bourses
etc
mais c'est jamais suffisant oui et ça
c'est une chose de rêver aux actualités
parce que le ministre de culture
l'éducation de l'espagne des seniors
ouverte
il voulait quitter la bourse à les
étudiants erasmus vous voulez rouler de
la bourse à cause de la crise la
solution s'est arrêté c'est une chose de
très très mauvaises je ne peux pas aller
en erasmus a invité à paris ce billet le
plus cher alors ça veut dire si je n'ai
pas de dettes pour étudier pour être
réussie il n'a pas de sens de faire ça
tu ne peux pas le faire
un autre a entonné l'autre mois st je
pense ma région je serai absolument pas
ici parce que l'état italien je pense
que du point de vue de l'instruction
s'est mis encore pire que le tabac avec
comme l'état espagnol donc même moi je
suis pas en erasmus je fais un double
diplôme en droit italien et français
j'ai reçu rien de l'état et de mon
université italienne dont c'est
seulement grâce à ma région que je suis
là étaient parents aussi aimé parent et
vient oui mais ça montre aussi que ça
dépend des milieux oui louis ouais mais
c'est justement ça c'est enfin c'est un
vrai problème parce que c'est vrai que
les aras mu s'est ouvert à 3% je crois
des étudiants en france est absolument
fin c'est absolument rien surtout quand
on sait que enfin le budget au niveau
européen est en train de saper
complètement
les bourses etc c'est vraiment le
fondement d'une découverte des autres
pays de création d'un vrai nom vrai
sentiment d'appartenance quoi c'est par
là qu'on construit de citoyens européens
finalement on parle d'erasmus on parle
des programmes pour les jeunes pour
justement leur permettre de se déplacer
et d'étudier dans d'autres pays
quid de la mobilité dans le travail
aujourd'hui en europe et entonner l'eau
est allé enquêter ils avaient le tintin
reporter à son tour il a été guidé par
thierry scharff on suit cette petite
pérégrinations dans paris à la recherche
d'informations sur la mobilité dans le
travail mais nous dit antonello
étudiants erasmus au droit français et
italiens la cité universitaire
internationale
il connaît bien c'est là qu'il vit c'est
pas seulement italien mais je viens de
la vallée d'aoste est très attaché à sa
région automne et l'eau est aussi un
catholique pratiquant qui sert
régulièrement la messe à notre-dame
étudiant dans l'emploi c'est simple mais
pour ceux qui veulent travailler à
l'ombre si la mobilité de l'emploi est
garanti par le droit européen dans la
réalité et malgré la crise les européens
bouchent très peu c'est un second rendez
vous avec catherine de wenden
spécialiste des questions migratoires
c'est un élément de la citoyenneté
européenne qui prend beaucoup de retard
par rapport à beaucoup de droits et
jusqu'en 2004 3 % seulement des
européens
travailler dans un autre pays européen
que le leur
ce qui veut dire que les européens
profitent et peut finalement de cette
possibilité de s'expatrier dans un autre
pays européen
ceux qui vivent déjà en européen et en
travailleurs européens à l'intérieur de
l'europe ce sont les plus qualifiés et
non contrairement aux idées reçues ce ne
sont pas les femmes de ménage bulgare ni
même le plombier polonais qui constitue
le plus gros des troupes des migrants
européens
mais avoir des diplômes ne garantit pas
de trouver un job de niveau équivalent
juliana est plutôt chanceuse venu
rejoindre son amoureux qui a été muté à
paris elle a décroché un cdi en trois
mois mais elle qui était agent
territorial d'une petite ville du
piémont a dû accepter un emploi de
vendeuse chez moi c'est parce que
il y a de travail je crois que c'est
important de
d'être un peu adaptable peut-être on ne
trouve pas à
toujours le travail qu'on me fasse des
annonces pour moi c'est ça en italie
j'étais en technicienne maintenant je
changer complètement de demain ça c'est
importante peut-être pas très loin on
voit donc giuliana que tu as rencontré
en tenez l'autre parce que ça montre que
la mobilité européenne est si évidente
que ça théo oui donc on a entendu dans
le reportage que seulement 3 % des
européens travaillent à l'étranger
on peut dire sur le montre pour cent
mais on peut dire 3% c'est déjà pas mal
être
effectivement ça dépend c'est moi
j'adore toujours la vision positive en
général optimistic tu peux le regarder
avec un avis négatif
et donc c'est seulement le 3% ou tu peux
le regarder avec un avis positif à lille
à ma question tu trouves ça comment
positif positif
évidemment et tu penses que ça va
évoluer tu penses que je pouvais en
italie où on fera ma question
personnelle je vais travailler je pense
que je voudrais rentrer dans ma région
vallée d'aoste avec les chèvres les
vaches parce que moi j'adore ma région
mais avec tous ce bagage culturel et
surtout cette ouverture d'accord avec
cette volonté de rentrer chez soi rama
yade qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
finalement de se dire que on se déplace
pour aller voir ailleurs mais là on est
bien chez soi quand même ça prouve que
en fait la citoyenneté européenne est
quand même un privilège un privilège sur
le plan politique dans la mesure où
parler dans un continent qui finalement
malgré ses difficultés présente certains
avantages
il vaut mieux être européen que d'être
en sortie 102 pays où les droits de
l'homme sont bafoués
mais en même temps
c'est un privilège son poids économique
aussi on n'est pas européen par hasard
on est européen parce qu'on a les moyens
de sortir de son pays d'aller ailleurs
quand on regarde le cas de la france
mais c'est tellement difficile de passer
on le voit pour quand on propose des
emplois dans la région de la côte et
chômeurs voilà c'est pas un détail quoi
6 6 2 et d'un certain sens oui voilà il
ya maintenant un emploi parce que c'est
un autre département notre région et
quand on est ressortissant d'un petit
village sous ledit village à côté c'est
l'étranger
donc vous imaginez l'europe internes et
leur ont va retomber retourner dans le
monde du travail mobile et on y revient
juste après
bien grand mot
séralini deux heures après l'agrément
petit avec l'europe pas besoin d'aller
très loin pour exploiter la misère de
son voisin surtout par temps de crise
c'est le cas de travailleurs portugais
embauchés dans le languedoc par un
patron d'une exploitation viticole
appliquant le niveau de salaire
portugais j'ai travaillé jour dès la
semaine j'avais pas se décourager et gt
5 6 et 12 13 14 ans avait pas les jours
500 euros soit l'équivalent d'un smic
portugais la parade des fiches de paie
déclarant à mille temps une pratique
répandue mais tout à fait frauduleuses
petite visite à la cgt une première pour
entonner l'eau qui a pu s'essayer un
nouveau nick
le syndicat français dénonce l'émergence
de nouveaux travailleurs européens low
cost rendue possible par certaines
failles de la réglementation européenne
c'est le cas par exemple des
travailleurs détachés un salarié par
exemple qui vient travailler en france
et dont le contrat a été signé ailleurs
qu'en france pendant deux ans 24 mois il
est possible que les cotisations
sociales que paye son employeur soit
celle du pays d'origine de ce salarié
donc on arrive à des différences on va
dire de coût salarial global de 30 à 40%
pour moi c'est de la libre concurrence
totalement faussée et donc quelques l
europe pour reconstruire
est ce que c'est une europe avec du
dumping social ou bien c'est une europe
avec une harmonisation vers le haut des
droits pour les salariés
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
créer ainsi la mobilité dans le travail
l'a favorisé pour certains c'est
finalement créé des travailleurs low
cost jules je pense pour ce qu'ils ont
fait cette europe là oui il ya un autre
exemple que les travailleurs détachés
c'est pas qu'on utilise en parce qu'elle
y est pour rien mais l'allemagne par
exemple est en train de passer des
partenariats avec la grèce par exemple
pour faire venir des trains et des
jeunes travailleurs grecs des jeunes
diplômés qui vont travailler avec les
salaires minimums de la grèce essart
effectivement sacré de la concurrence
entre les travailleurs des différentes
nationalités enfin on ne peut pas d'un
côté pleurer qu'il n'y a pas d'identité
européenne que les gens sont
eurosceptiques et d'à côté en fait
construire quotidiennement la
concurrence entre les gens entre les
citoyens européens
on sait que les modèles économiques de
tous les pays européens mais un son
différent qui sont pas dans le même état
l'allemagne vient de passer un smic qui
était déjà une réussite sociale mais
malheureusement on n'est pas un état
fédéral
ils aient voté ou lait pas voter non pas
encore on se dit oh merkel l'a promis je
compte juste j'ai pas dit que fin du
jour au lendemain que là qu'on allait
mettre un smic amis 1200 euros par mois
dans tous les pays en revanche ce qui
est possible c'est par exemple fédéral
c'est embêtant mais ce qui est possible
en revanche c'est un salaire par exemple
proportionnelle au salaire minimum du
pays explique proportionnelle au salaire
minimum du pays donc disons un smic 20%
au-dessus du salaire min
du pays dans chaque pays ça c'est
possible et ça déjà c'est déjà une
avancée qui permet d'éviter la
concurrence et que c'est la deuxième
chose c'est que quand on travaille je
travaille dans un pays bas ils payent
les charges sociales du pays et pas les
charges sociales de son pays d'origine
est ce qu'on est en train de créer des
travailleurs locaux c'est incroyable je
pense qu'il ya deux deux solutions en
attendant un jour une harmonisation
d'abord sur la question de
l'élargissement
parce que c'est ça en fait tant qu'on
était des pays à peu près similaire en
terme de poids économique ça allait et
quand vous plus vous élargissez à des
pays où les différences sociales et
réglementaires sont tellement fortes et
bien vous êtes confrontés de plus en
plus à ce problème donc je pense que
pour l'élargissement faut peut-être
aller moins vite et deuxièmement
travailler sur la croissance quand le
travail est rare ben voilà vous avez une
concurrence entre les pauvres parce que
c'est à ça qu'on ait réduit
c'est à dire que les pauvres des pays du
plombier polonais ou autres qui sont
confrontés à nos pauvres de chez nous et
qui rafle la mise
pardon de tenir un vocabulaire un peu
donc on prend militants mais c'est tout
c'est l'employeur qui va essayer à
travers les différentes réglementations
en les contournant en jouant du droit
parce qu'il ya des avocats qui
permettent de faire ça et parce que le
droit j'ai tout fait à m voilà de
profiter de cette situation
donc à un moment donné plutôt que de se
partager un travail qui se fait de plus
en plus rare entre des gens qui sont
pauvres
eh bien il faut peut-être poser la
question de la croissance et c'est là
encore une fois que moi j'interpelle
aurait volontiers les autorités
monétaires européennes qui ont fait des
choix qui peut être un moment s'imposait
de lutte drastique de contre l'inflation
mais la contrepartie de ça ça a été une
croissance bas niveau donc low cost
j'aimerais qu'on termine par la question
là de notre partenaire atlantico on va
parler maintenant de la question de la
solidarité
est-ce que ça définit pas aussi le
citoyen européen
il ya quelque chose qui était vraiment
marquant pendant la crise de la dette
depuis 2008 c'est que ni les allemands
ni les français n'avaient envie de payer
pour les déficits des grecs aux états
unis qui sont aussi nos zone monétaire
commune avec le dollar
le massachusetts ne se pose jamais la
question de renflouer les caisses du
kentucky ou l'alabama s'ils en ont
besoin jusqu'à présent la citoyenneté
européenne elle était bon
construite sur du juridique sur du
respect des règles comment est ce qu'on
fait pour créer une citoyenneté où il
est un peu plus d'identité un peu plus
de solidarité lorraine
théo auxquels réagir je pense que de
manière paradoxale la crise a réussi à
nous faire réaliser que nous sommes
responsables des uns des autres qu'il
faut s'occuper aussi d'économie grecque
portugaise espagnole
même si c'est difficile ça crée
l'identité européenne parce que ça n'a
pas créé du repli selon toi sacré de la
solidarité la crise oui enfin non je dis
pas que ça crée t créer de la solidarité
je crois que ça a créé la enfin on a
réalisé une conscience une gueule et la
conscience européenne on a réalisé que
finalement on était tous les les uns aux
autres et qu'il fallait qu'on apprenne à
travailler ensemble liés ou dépendants
johan selon toi j'ai vu une reportage en
espagne qui parlait de la soirée
solidarité comme la nouvelle
colonialisme d'allemagne il voit une
pays avec beaucoup de problèmes et il
l'aide mais a il contrôle sept pays
alors je pense que oui ils existent
il existe déjà une super un euro péenne
il faut qu'elles existent mais avec une
solidarité sans une butte monétaire faut
être solidaire et désintéressé jules je
pense que les seuls à se sentir citoyen
européen actuellement c'est les élites
en fait mais pour une raison qu'en fait
elles sont toujours sentis européenne
les élites même à l'époque des
monarchies avant les états-nations elle
se sentait déjà européenne et le jour où
en revanche le reste de la population et
enfin en vrai l'entière population se
sentira citoyenne européenne c'est le
jour où l'europe sera synonyme de
progrès social démocratie ce qui n'est
pas du tout actuellement le cas
antonella en concluant sa marraine à
l'esprit devises au début de
l'unification italienne
on utilisait cette phrase maintenant on
a fait l'italie il faut faire les
italiens
je pense de ne pas faire une arnaque
ronis mme allard utilisant maintenant ça
veut dire qu'on est en train de faire
l'europe mais on peut dire que
maintenant on a fait l'europe
il faut faire les européens et ça c'est
la chose la plus la plus difficile de
martiens tenait le rama yade
vu de tous ces échanges et de ce que
vous pensiez déjà avant la citoyenneté
européenne
vaste programme on va se marrer mais ça
prendra du temps mais je pense qu'on
finira par y arriver
d'abord parce que par rapport au reste
du monde
les européens ça existe aux yeux des
autres un reste à ce que ça existe
à nos yeux à nous on est à la veille
d'élections européennes en france et on
nous prédit que le premier parti de
france
c'est le front national qui le parti le
plus de robes la france moteur un pays
fondateur de l'union européenne moteur
du couple franco allemand l'ont pas
n'importe quel pays où le premier parti
de france
ce serait le parti le plus europhile
c'est quand même inquiétant je me pose
sur la question de savoir pourquoi ceux
qui critiquent l'europe envoie à
bruxelles mais gens qui veulent avoir
les europhobes il faut envoyer des gens
européen convaincu mais mes critiques
merci beaucoup à rama yade pour le
prochain numéro de génération europe on
se retrouvera et justement on posera la
question de quelle europe
voulez vous la voulez vous social
politique ou économique c'est au
prochain numéro
et